I believe you mentioned earlier that you
felt you'd learned everything from film
school within the first six months yes
two weeks I mean once you learn our work
the equipment it's you know I mean it's
sort of a separate conversation in my
view college in general like I think
college is a racket frankly unless
you're going to be a doctor or whatever
we really you know d does the world need
English literature majors and stuff like
that to spend a hundred grand it's like
just spend 5 grand you know get books
and stuff like that so film school I
think you know is valuable to a certain
degree but for me once I learn how to
work the equipment I don't need somebody
telling me you know screenwriting theory
and all that kind of for my
experience is the best way to learn how
to make movies is to a do them and be
watch them and you know listen too deep
DVD commentary thank you yeah so yeah
once I learned how to work the camera it
was kind of like okay I get it let's
move on
you